welcome to the show everybody happy
Thanksgiving as we get ready for
Thanksgiving to be the big day tomorrow
the final exam hope you've hope you've
studied because you know the media the
media realizes that we're all a bunch of
incompetent helpless morons and we don't
know how to speak to our own families
around the dinner table without precise
instructions and so fortunately our
betters in the media are always eager to
help us out in this regard and to give
us you know to give us those two
tutorials which is why around this time
every year we are treated to a slew of
conversational instruction manuals from
the media telling us how to talk to our
family not just not just what to talk
about but also how to talk about those
things so this year as it happens our
white knights our knights in shining
armor armor have have gone above and
beyond the call of duty and here's just
a quick sampling I looked on Google and
here's just a quick sampling of the how
to talk to your family articles which is
a a burgeoning genre quick assembly
these are something having have been
published recently so we have how to
talk about the economy with your family
on Thanksgiving here's how to fact-check
your family got the Thanksgiving dinner
table how to deal with climate skeptics
at Thanksgiving dinner how to talk about
race at Thanksgiving how to talk about
politics at your Thanksgiving table how
to talk about the truth and Trump at
Thanksgiving how to talk about
reproductive freedom with your
anti-choice family members at
Thanksgiving how to talk about in how to
talk about impeachment at Thanksgiving
how to talk to your misogynistic family
members this holiday season how to talk
about gun control with your family at
Thanksgiving dinner how to talk about
your career during the holidays how to
talk about medical cannabis at
Thanksgiving dinner how to talk about
tik-tok with your family this
Thanksgiving how to talk to your family
about anime at Thanksgiving vegan here's
how to talk to your family at
Thanksgiving how to handle money
conversations on Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving in the age of Donald Trump
nine ways to avoid political food fights
five ways to talk to your pro Trump
family on Thanksgiving five things to
talk about at Thanksgiving that aren't
politics how to have constructive
conversations at a dividend at a
divisive Thanksgiving 15 things you
should never discuss at Thanksgiving
dinner why you should talk about
feminism with your family over the
holidays seven ways to talk to your
racist uncle this Thanksgiving and
finally men are lonely men are angry men
fear death
Thanksgiving is the time to talk about
it and don't don't worry because if
you're wondering okay but how do I talk
about Thanksgiving on Thanksgiving well
CNN has an article about that they have
that base covered they have a how to
talk to kids about Thanksgiving so they
were so that so that they really get it
so I know I know that's a lot to take it
this is a lot of material to study
precise instructions for every
imaginable topic lists of what to talk
about what not to talk about it's very
confused especially when they they
contradict a little bit because on one
hand it's you know how to dominate your
family in a politics debate and how to
avoid politics so how do you do both of
those things I don't know and that's
what you really need to sit down you
know draw up a Venn diagram I mean you
just got to work through this and for me
this is why I'm always up until 3 a.m.
or 4 a.m. the month the morning before
Thanksgiving cramming you know I'm
popping at at all and I'm trying to do
as much studying as I can I've got
flashcards and everything because this
is normal right this is how normal
people are
we need a writer at Vox or NPR calm to
tell us how to talk to our own families
because I have no idea how to do it and
so the first thing I do is I google it
which is
I did here I think the main thing is
this you want to make sure and this is
so crucial you want to sure that nothing
spontaneous or sincere or lively or
interesting or real or alive happens
when you're with your loved ones
okay this is not a time for sincerity
you wouldn't want to you know just talk
to your family you would want to do that
it's important that you have the bullet
points the script in fact and don't
don't feel like there's anything wrong
with this I know in a traditional test
you're not allowed to bring your notes
with you but that this is a test where
you're allowed to bring your notes so I
will bring I'll have a folder or binder
with all of my notes and I've got it
carefully organized and so if somebody
brings up climate change where they
bring up gun control all I say is just
hang on a second I flipped through you
know I start flipping through and if I
find my notes and then I I make my
twelve pre-approved points and then I
say discussion terminated and I stand up
and I walk immediately out of the room
and this is just this is how you spend
time with your family
and you have a lovely lovely
Thanksgiving that way okay a few other
things to talk about as we get ready for
the holiday season to officially kick
off here but first before we do a word
from the last coat you know the thing
about the holidays is we all look
forward to it but it holidays they come
with winter time right it's kind of it's
sort of a package deal and I know for me
especially during the winter things are
getting cold muddy slushy snowy and it
makes it really hard to keep that car
looking nice and that's why I want to
talk about the last coat it's a
proprietary versatile durable all-in-one
easy to use all surface do-it-yourself
coating that gives cars a slick
mirror-like finish in just minutes also
it's great for glass vinyl leather
stainless steel countertops electric
screens most fabrics and a lot more so
this is you one time what versatile this
thing does it all now
of course this is a great gift idea
especially if you have a car lover in
the family but if you're a selfish son
of a gun like myself then you're gonna
give this gift to yourself which is
which is what I which is what I do
because like we talked about yesterday
on the show you can't you can't rely on
your family to get you a good gift so
you got to just get gifts yourself a pre
holiday gift to myself and I would
recommend that as well it creates a
protective shell on your car that
protects it from UV rays road salt
abrasive soaps stream temperatures much
more its protection and coating it last
erupted for six months and if you want
to know how this works and how other
people have how other people feel about
it the other customers will just look
and you'll see thousands of five-star
reviews online and for a limited time my
listeners can get a twenty five percent
discount on a 16 ounce bottle of the
last coat it's the most durable all
service DIY coating technology on the
market for reference an average sized
car only takes one or two ounces for
full coverage so you're getting a lot of
bang for your buck take advantage of
this 25% discount go to the last
koat.com slash Walsh type in Walsh 25 of
the check out again that's the last
koat.com slash Walsh and Walsh 25 at the
checkout to get 25% off the last coat is
an awesome gift idea for the car
enthusiasts in your family that's the
last coat comp slash Walsh and Walsh 25
at
to take advantage of this limited time
offer all right by the way here is Peeta
claiming that the Georgia Bulldog mascot
is being abused you see the tweet here
and you see the dog there in the rain
and Peeta says he looks miserable no dog
deserves to be packed up carted from
state to the state and paraded in front
of a stadium full of screaming fans
animals are not mascots Georgia must
retire retire what's the dog's name
Booga is that what they call him he
should be at home with a loving family
first of all
Bulldogs always look miserable okay
that's that's sort of their look they've
got resting depressed face so you can't
really judge a book by its cover as far
as that goes second though more to the
point what you see her is a dog in his
own private air condition ten taking a
nap while a bunch of humans stand in the
rain so who has it better here you see
the dog in his air condition ten just
hanging out and all the miserable people
on the rein and PETA is concerned about
the dog not to mention the dog travels
around the country has legions of
adoring fans is farmed over by everyone
has a diet better than me gets better
accommodations that I do when I travel
if you're looking for an example of a
neglected or abused animal you couldn't
possibly choose a worse example in this
this dog is like the Kardashian of dogs
he's a pampered celebrity so I'm just
not sure that that this is a good
example okay um here's something else
that annoyed me a little bit remember
John Schneider I think it's how you
pronounce his last name Herr Schneider
Papa John we'll just call him it used to
be a ubiquitous presence on TV
especially during the football season
and he's the guy who founded Papa John's
well he got ousted from his company a
year ago you may remember for alleged
racism and we'll get back to that in a
second we'll talk about why he was
actually Austin but Papa John did an
interview with WDRB in Louisville and
and clips from that interview went viral
yesterday with everybody sort of
cackling and mocking him for it
especially because of this part right
here listen I've had over 40 pizzas in
the last thirty days and it's not the
same pizza it's not the same product it
just doesn't taste as good the way
they're making the pizza the way they're
putting the pizza together is just not
fundamentally sound to what makes a Papa
John's Pizza a Papa John's Pizza it
sounds like you're saying that that it's
taking a huge hit since your departure
would you ever consider or do you want
to go back right now I don't want to go
back but this is still your baby it's
got your name on it your point Stefan
it's it's hard to watch this I mean
every single thing you can possibly do
wrong to mismanage this company
they're doing Snyder says he still loves
the company he built but he has sold
millions in stock and is no longer the
largest individual shareholder my
metaphor is there's no reason to be in
the car when the car crashes even if you
love the car if you were to walk back in
and CEO what do you think the employees
would say if the management team was out
leave and I went back you know they'd be
they'd be cheering maybe doing back
flips they'd be bouncing off the walls
okay so he says he ate 40 pizzas in a
month which which yeah is weird I don't
know if we're talking about 40 full
pizzas or 40 slices of pizzas throughout
a month because you know it's 40 slices
that would be about a slice and a third
per day that's not too bad still a lot
of pizza if we're talking 40 entire
pizzas then that's just deadly but and
yeah he looks a little bit sweaty there
and everything and that's the reason
this went viral because everyone's
snickering and pointing and laughing I
thought he ate 40 Pete says he looks so
sweaty what a freak that kind of thing
but this is just an example I think of
our of our stupid frivolous perpetually
adolescent culture because the real
story here is that this guy John
Schnatter he got railroaded smeared and
tossed under the bus by his own company
the company he founded these people that
you know they just threw him to the
wolves and stole his company from him so
remember what happened he was on a
conference call with people in this
company and a marketing agency and the
conference called the subject of the
call was about how to navigate racial
controversies as a company so during the
course of that discussion apparently
this is I guess according to him but I
don't think anyone else anyone ever
denied that this was the context of it
so during the course of that discussion
he used the n-word but he used it while
quoting racist things that other people
had said as an example of the sorts of
controversies that they're trying to
navigate right so he was basically
saying as an example of what they were
talking about
remember when so and so said said blank
so it was a quote or paraphrase he did
utter the syllables okay he did say the
word but the context was totally
innocuous and traditionally right intent
and context are important facets of
human conversation you need to take
those into account so if you say a bad
thing if you say a bad thing and I
repeat the bad thing you said by way of
informing others that the bad thing was
said I am NOT myself guilty of the bad
thing
right with with the n-word however it
has been decided that the word itself
just the actual word those letters put
together and the syllables somehow
transcend intent and context completely
so that intent and context make no
difference at all if the word is said by
someone with the wrong skin pigmentation
it doesn't matter why it was it it makes
no difference they're gonna lose their
job they're gonna lose everything that
obviously is insane
I was about to call it silliness but
it's a lot more than silliness when a
person loses his livelihood in his
reputation it becomes something much
more than silliness I think because we
must realize that it can a word is not a
magical spell okay a word itself the
power of a word all depends on the
intent and the manner in which the word
is used there there cannot be a single
word there is not a single word in in
existence that could never where there
could never be an innocent or an oculist
reason to use it even if there because
the reason could be something as simple
as I'm telling you what someone else
said or I'm reading it right
and besides you might say well he should
have said the word he should have just
said n-word okay yeah in terms of
self-preservation and navigating our
crazy politically correct culture then
yeah that's what he should have done I
think we all know that but if he had
said if he had said n-word rather than
just saying the word he would still be
communicating the words yes what doesn't
make any sense to me
you're still communicating it you're
everyone knows what you're what you mean
you're still caught you're still putting
the word in someone else's head you're
causing them to think about the thing
that you're conveying that's what
communication is so practically speaking
it's not really any different okay what
if he had spelled the word what if what
if rather than say n-word a rather than
say the word what have you had spelled
the entire word is that racist to spell
a word well I think we would all have to
agree no or maybe is it maybe it is so
you could say the first letter maybe the
second but you can't say the last three
what how how far does this go and what
if you spell the word then you again
have communicated the word and put the
word into someone else's head which is
the same thing practically speaking as
just saying so
this guy loses his job and his
reputation is destroyed because of this
and and the reason why that happened is
that someone on the conference call went
and leaked it to the media and it's
company threw him under the bus he's
kicked out of the place that he built
and he's remembered now as a racist even
though there's no evidence that he is
and the most the headline that most
people take from this is that it's funny
because he said he ate a lot of pizzas
he said in that interview how the people
that threw him under the bus he made it
to millionaires
he made the millionaires and then they
set out to destroy him and that's that
sounds accurate it's sounds like that's
exactly what happened so shouldn't we be
defending this guy I mean isn't this I
never understood this way as concerned
as everybody is about canceled not
everybody at least people who aren't on
the far left so as concerned as people
aside from far leftists are about the
canceled culture this seems to be one of
the most egregious examples of it and it
no one really cared when it happened I
never quite got that I mean this guy got
completely railroaded
in a situation where it's obvious I mean
they're having this conversation
everybody on the conference call
understands what they're talking about
and understands what he's saying and
then one of them went at least one of
them went and and decided to take this
and just destroy the guy but that's how
evil is that that's but yeah it doesn't
matter because he ate a lot of pizzas
and you look sweaty in the interview and
you know that's that's all that matters
it's it's crazy to me all right
um listen up by the way IIIi know you I
think you need to do something very
simple if you're planning on buying a
daily wire membership today they're
gonna be surprised and we say this but
don't do it I know it sounds
counterintuitive and it is but trust me
we don't want your money
today we love your money but just not
today remember this Friday is Black
Friday and I've been told that we're
offering amazing deals like you would
kick yourself in the pants I don't know
how you would kick yourself in the pants
that's what that's that's what my script
says here you would kick yourself in the
pants if you missed these deals you kick
yourself how would you kick yourself in
the pants well anyway you don't want to
miss these deals that's the point so you
want to get the deals on Black Friday on
Black Friday there's gonna be crazy
deals if you want to become a daily wire
member and so I'm just warning you if
you do it today
and then you could have saved all that
money in two days so wait till Friday
but then on Friday you want to go and
sign up become a daily wire remember all
kinds of deals all kinds of perks that
come with it on Friday okay there was an
article in The Economist a few days ago
titled the roots of the gender pay gap
lie in childhood and it's all about the
the child penalty about how having
children lowers a woman's lifetime
earnings and the article seems to be
moan that fact so here's the first
paragraph it says it is well known that
parenthood tends to hurt women's careers
but not men's numerous studies have
shown that as a group having children
lowers women's lifetime earnings an
outcome known as the child penalty a
wide range of individual decisions
account for this effect some women work
for you hours or not at all when their
children are young others switch to jobs
that are more fan
friendly but lower-paid there's also a
substantial variation in the size of the
earnings decline ranging from zero all
the way up to 100 percent in the case of
women who stopped working altogether and
then it goes on from there just two
quick points I wanted to make about this
number one calling it the phrase child
penalty to me it's just another example
of the
sort of scorn and disregard that we heap
on children which which I'm hesitant to
use the word because it's so overused
but the I would almost call it a sort of
bigotry that we have against children in
this culture
we talked about you know the people are
very open and talking about children as
burdens or how they hate being around
kids in public and and and and so on
I don't think that's the right phrase to
use child penalty and I think that the
women who choose to have kids and then
make adjustments to their lives maybe
they get a lower paying job so they can
be home more maybe they leave their job
and they stay home with the kids I don't
think that these women feel like they're
being penalized this is what they want
to do
and it makes sense really because as
much as the media might be mone the loss
of earnings that comes from having kids
you have to think when you're on your
deathbed
well I very much doubt that there's ever
been someone on their deathbed looking
back at their life and regretting that
they hadn't earned more income
I just I don't think that's the kind of
thing that you're gonna be worried about
and we all sort of know that right in
there there there are many things that
we spend our days worrying about and
caring about that we know when we are on
our deathbed unless we die suddenly in a
car accident something but if we if
we're on our deathbed and we have that
moment we know that we're going to you
know we're gonna regret spending all the
time worrying about those things
and so lifetime earnings is one of those
things on the other hand when you're on
your deathbed I don't think you're gonna
regret having children
factor your regrets will be
you had kids but they you didn't spend
more time with them
that's where the regrets are
I certainly and I'm certain that no
one's ever been on their deathbed and
regretted and wished that they had spent
less time around their family and their
kids I don't think anyone's ever been
lying there hours before death and said
oh man I wish I had taken more hours at
work so that would been away from my
kids more right no one is saying that so
I think the the decision to spend more
time with your kids rather than even if
it means sacrificing money that's that's
a decision that most people will and
ultimately will not live to regret and
and even if you do regret I mean if
you're on your deathbed and you're
worried about your lifetime earnings and
how much money you made that's only
going to be because you want to leave
something for your kids which means you
have to have them
if you had no kids and you spent your
entire life focused on yourself and on
attaining material goods for yourself
that's not gonna mean anything to you
you're gonna see how empty and Hollow
that actually was all right before we
get to some emails and we wrap it up for
the week
speaking of Thanksgiving rules I thought
it would be helpful and necessary to
review as we head into Thanksgiving the
rules and restrictions for Thanksgiving
as they apply to the food these are as
of now unwritten rules but of course
upon my ascension to the throne they
will be engraved and stone it literally
engraved and so in fact I'm gonna have
all my laws in carved to the to the side
of a mountain so everyone can see it
it's going to be a pretty big mountain
because I've got a lot of laws and rules
and this will be one of them so
Thanksgiving a few guidelines here I
think I've got maybe five rules for for
the for how you handle the food on
Thanksgiving
number one no seafood is permitted
seafood in general is overrated but I'm
not going to stop you from eating it if
you want to tonight or if you want to
one Friday okay if you want to waste
your time having shrimp or salmon or
something then go ahead I don't know why
you would do that when beef exists but
you knock yourself out but Thanksgiving
is not a time for that and and really
none of the holidays are we're talking
about Thanksgiving we're talking about
Christmas we're talking about Easter
none of those are times for for seafood
it's not substantial enough of a dish to
have a place on the table and I know I
go through this because my wife's family
their big seafood fan fans and I've got
to watch them like a hawk because every
holiday occasion they're looking they're
looking for an excuse to put some
seafood on the table and so this is sub
this is something I struggle with and I
go through in my own personal life
number two absolutely no pasta on
Thanksgiving this is America pasta on
Thanksgiving is wildly inappropriate and
unethical Thanksgiving is a time for
American foods not pasta and don't give
me the whole what about mac and cheese
okay first of all mac and cheese
macaroni and cheese on Thanksgiving how
old are you 4 and it is pasta and
besides and here's the main point of the
pasta number one not American number two
you it Thanksgiving is a time when it
comes to the side dishes this is a time
for potatoes to really shine and you're
not gonna put pasta and potatoes on the
same plate okay you're not gonna put
macaroni and cheese right next to your
mashed potatoes that doesn't make any
sense so this is about the potatoes it's
not about the pasta again you give the
pasta any other time except on holidays
number three I will allow multiple
proteins at the table you want to have
ham in addition to Turkey that's fine
but Turkey is the star Turkey gets the
the prime place on the table it's at the
center of the action
if there's only one protein that damn
well better be turkey ham has Christmas
ham also as Easter okay so it gets two
holidays and ham can take a backseat
we can't let it steal the spotlight on
Thanksgiving it needs to learn its role
and know its place number four all side
dishes green beans potatoes stuffing
cranberry sauce etc
must be cooked in a traditional way this
is not a time for experimentation this
is a not a time for showboating
Thanksgiving is it's kind of like a
Rolling Stones concert okay if you're
going to a Rolling Stones concert you
don't want to hear the song they cooked
up in 2016 you want to hear the same
stuff they've been playing for 50 years
if you went to a Rolling Stone concert
in 1972 and you you want the concert you
go to in 2019 to sound exactly like that
concert in 1972 and it's the same thing
with Thanksgiving we want the same
dishes that our grandmother's made
basically unless your grandmother was a
communist who put marshmallows and sweet
potatoes in which case she and you are
getting shipped to the gulag because her
reign of terror is finally coming to an
end and she will answer for those crimes
number five pumpkin pie and we'll get
into the desert and and you know I'm
shocked that this is even controversial
there are people that try to argue with
this and I find it I find it just
stunning pumpkin pie is the primary
dessert at Thanksgiving with homemade
whipped cream you know if you put Cool
Whip on that table that's 15 years of
hard labor so you want the homemade
whipped cream with the pumpkin pie now
if you want again it's kind of like the
turkeys got the turkeys the star you
want to put something else along with it
that's fine you want to put an apple pie
down that's fine I'm not gonna have an
issue with that you want to put some
other kind want to put brownies down or
cookies that's why you did there there
around the peripheral around the edges
but you got the pumpkin pie right there
in the middle
cherry pie is a disgrace doesn't belong
on any table for any occasion chocolate
pies are not pies that's just pudding
with crust okay it's not elevated enough
yeah I've got no problem with pudding
with crust but it's just not elevated
enough for the Thanksgiving occasion and
I think those are
the basic rules a and if you stick with
that you'll be fine now you might ask
upon my ascension how would I enforce
these rules in order to enforce them
wouldn't it be necessary that I
basically abolish everyone's privacy
rights completely and the answer to that
is yes I of course absolutely that's the
whole point of being a tyrannical
dictator and I've always been consistent
about this you know I believe in
constitutional rights and liberties for
me you know I and the most important
thing so for me right now as a person
without power yeah I want everyone have
those rights so that I can have them but
obviously when I'm in power I you know I
have all the power so I don't care about
the rights anymore so that's gonna go
out the window and here's here's gonna
essentially be my strategy I'm gonna
have my military activated of course on
Thanksgiving and they're gonna go into
they'll be in every town basically and
they're gonna do random checks there's
gonna come in to a random house do a
check of the dinner table make sure
everything's in working order they're
not going to be able to look at every
house but this is where my reign is
gonna be very much a reign of terror so
I'm gonna make it clear that you know if
you observe infractions at your dinner
table by your family members and you
report them you'll get a $10,000 reward
if you don't you'll be executed so in
and I think with that terror along with
the military I think you know we could
really basically snuff out all of the
Thanksgiving infractions which for me
from from my observations have become
far too widespread so that's what you
have to look forward to but you might as
well even before I'm dictator you might
as well start now and just start
following the rules ahead of time so
that by the time I'm sitting on the
throne you know you've kind of gotten
into the groove of things all right
let's go to emails Matt Walsh Oh at
gmail.com
Matt Welsh Oji Malla comm this is from
Nathan says mr. Walsh I'm a freshman in
high school and we were having our first
AP Human Geography debate in a few weeks
on whether English should be the
official language of the US I feel like
I know what your opinion is but I was
trying to get some good counter
arguments to the whole diversity as our
strengths stitch stick
because the counter-arguments I come up
with sound cruel and unfeeling which
brings into question why I'm asking you
theocratic fascist but I would love your
input yeah I guess if you're looking for
answers that are not cruel and unfeeling
then you're talking to the wrong guy but
here's what I would say it's well it's
more of a question Nathan that I would
pose to anyone who goes with the
diversity is our strength thing all you
have to ask them is why is it our
strength so you're saying diversity is
our strength okay
why what's so great about it now I'm
guessing that most people who use that
line will be defeated right there
you've already beat them because they
probably can't explain why it matters
they're just gonna start stumbling
around and they won't be able to come up
with an answer but and that's because
they're so used to the assumption that
diversity matters that they've never
actually stopped to think about why it
does or if it even does but if they come
up with an answer I assume that will
have something to do with how we are all
enriched you know by the input in the
influence of other cultures and how it
makes for a richer and more vibrant
culture and and so on but here's the
issue it's really hard to be enriched by
the influence of other people it's
really hard to even have a culture that
can be improved by diversity in the
first place if we can't understand each
other so communication the ability to
communicate is one of the most
fundamental most essential ingredients
in any culture and in any country you
literally cannot have a country or a
culture if the people aren't able to
communicate and that's what this is
about
so whether diversity is heart strength
or not communication is still essential
so you don't need to argue on diversity
maybe that's what you're worried about
well how am I gonna you don't have to
argue that point grant the point and say
okay well in order for that to make a
difference we need to be able to
communicate
I mean how am I really gonna be
influenced and enriched and and all of
that by someone else if I can't
understand what they're saying to me
let's see this is
this is from no name here says I
understand your position on this but our
family has always really enjoyed getting
Christmas ornaments particularly
handcrafted one one notable example is
how my sisters and their friends have
given each other ornaments from time to
time generally with some sort of
particular meanings such as a clear ball
with elvish runes painted on the side we
have a tradition in our family where we
pray for the people who gave us the
ornament since nearly every ornament on
our tree is from someone and many of
them are handmade I have a bead craft
that I make that I have used to make
ornaments for my family such as a 3d
wreath or a Christmas tree one year my
dad and I carved a Christmas tree and a
wreath out of a nice block of ash wood
for my mother well I certainly
understand not wanting to get a red
bauble for for Christmas sometimes an
ornament can have a meaning or worth
above its material value it goes back to
the saying it's the thought that counts
but in a good way the meaning behind the
gift is what is important about it well
I just disagree
the thought doesn't mean anything you
know what do I care what thought was in
your head when you got me a gift do I
like it can I use it can I eat it okay
these are the questions that I'm asking
myself this is from Alex says I share
your perspective that sex ed should not
be taught in schools the way it is and
in the case of schools in England
teaching primary school kids how to
masturbate is horrifying but I was
wondering how you feel an STD education
in schools it seems that to me that this
also should be left to the parents but
considering there are many parents that
feel uncomfortable talking about stuff
like this with their kids would it not
be beneficial for schools to teach
students about STDs obviously this
should wait until the kids are at least
13 or 14 but it seems clear to me that
it's better for all students to know the
dangers of STDs before any of them are
sexually active thanks and love the show
yeah Alex well yeah they should know
about STDs the same way we teach them
about any other disease so this is a
fact that's relevant to biology and
that's how I would approach it that was
my point was sex head that you don't
need a specific sex ed subject you want
to teach the biology of human
reproduction okay you do that in science
class you want to teach anatomy you have
theirs that's also a scientist
topic STDs again
that's a topic that is covered in an
academic environment it's when they get
into their own ideology their own
perspective on sexual activity and
everything that's when we have a problem
finally this is from Tony says hi Matt
I'm not a parent myself but I respect
the fact that you don't seem to follow
New Age slash liberal methods of
parenting I'd love to hear you go on a
rant about parents who let their kids
misbehave in public I was out the other
day and saw a kid acting out majorly
while his mother was wasn't doing
anything about it terrible parents are
why we have multiple generations now
spoiled brats what do you think
well Tony I agree there are a lot of bad
parents these days I agree that a lot of
parents let their kids get away with
everything and that those kids go on to
inflict society with themselves being
generally spoiled lazy entitled and so
on I agree this is a problem and much of
it goes back to parenting so I wouldn't
deny that I'm with you there but maybe
I'll throw a curveball at you today by
not giving you the rant you asked for
because there's another side to this
that you as a non parent I think
especially probably need to hear you
didn't really give me any details about
this situation that you witnessed with
the mom and her child I don't know where
you were I don't know what the kid was
doing I don't know what his mom was
doing or not doing it's possible that
what you saw was totally egregious and
inexcusable and I'd certainly believe
that I've witnessed things like that we
all have but so I don't know if what
I'll say here applies to this situation
or not maybe it does or doesn't but it
does apply to many situations that
you're likely to see so here's here's
what I would caution you you can't judge
a parent based on one short snapshot
okay you can't and we all do this but we
shouldn't you can't look at a parent in
one brief isolated stressful moment see
how they're acting see how they're
reacting see how they're handling it and
then make sweeping judgments calling
them terrible and so on because that's
not fair unless the parent is doing
something really really as I said
egregious really harmful and awful in
which case okay but but barring that I
don't think you can dismiss a parent
based on how you see them react in one
isolated incident to a child that's
misbehaving when you don't know the
context you don't know anything about
them so your parenting is really hard it
is and it's unrelenting kids don't give
you a break they don't take your stress
into account really especially at a
certain age they're not gonna look at
you and say hey you know looks like
dad's having a tough day maybe I'll go
easy on the kids aren't gonna say that I
don't mean to make parenting sound like
non-stop misery
it isn't but it is hard and so you see a
parent out in public not really being
johnny-on-the-spot with the discipline
and and and you you you could assume
that that's a terrible parent fine but
maybe it's been a really tough day with
that kid or a tough week or a tough year
and the mom on top of that maybe is
dealing with problems at work maybe
there's a sick family member maybe
there's financial problems maybe she's
just taken the child out to spend some
time with them making an effort the kids
not cooperating mom really doesn't want
to yell she doesn't want to punish you
feels like she's been doing too much of
that's already this week and this this
today so she tries to be patient she
tries to be lenient because she's
emotionally worn out and she feels like
she's been coming down too hard on the
kid lately and she feels like patients
and lenience right now is the best
approach and so what you interpret as
lazy parenting and bad parenting and
terrible parenting maybe it's actually
heroic restraint on her part maybe this
is actually a mother who desperately
loves her son and her family and is just
trying as much as she can to do the
right thing and and she knows you're
watching him she knows that you're
heaping this judgment on her but she's
doing what she thinks is right I mean
who knows maybe that's the case
maybe it's not I've just created a
scenario out of whole cloth who knows
maybe as I said maybe she really is a
terrible parent neglectful mother
the kids are snot-nosed brat destined to
be a societal leech maybe that's the
case but I don't know and you don't know
either and that's the point so why not
extend the woman and her child a little
bit of grace and just assume that she's
a good mother doing her best
I assume the worst and someone that you
don't even know that's my point and I'm
I'm not lecturing you I this I I do this
myself even though I am a parent myself
and I know how it is and this is
something parents do to each other and
it's crazy because you know you as
someone who's not a parent at least you
have an excuse that you don't you don't
really know how it is because you never
had kids but as parents we know how it
is and we've all been in tough spots
with our kids and we've all had kids
that have acted out at some point in
public and we've all felt overwhelmed
we've all been through that all of us
yet we still will even judge each other
when we see parents doing things that we
have done and being in situations that
we've been in we'll still judge them ie
just the other day I was out at the
stores in the parking lot about to pull
out of the grocery store his mother
comes out and she you know she's got her
kid by the arm and she could tell she's
furious I don't know what happened
something happened in the store
obviously she's screaming at the kid and
she puts him in the car slams the door
walks around and she's just fuming right
and I happen to see this and
and for a moment I thought to myself oh
that woman needs to get her act together
this is embarrassing
you don't act like this in public and
it's true that we should refrain from
public scenes of that short of that
sword and screaming at your child really
is not the right approach but then I had
to stop myself and think yeah I have no
idea I have no freaking clue what's
going on in that woman's life I have no
idea I mean her husband may have just
died of cancer again I don't know it's
possible
probably not but but maybe all I've seen
of this woman I don't know her name
don't know anything about her all I've
seen is this one snapshot this one
60-second clip of her at her absolute
worst furious at her kid we've all been
furious at our kids before we all have
and so I happen to see that just that
one glimpse her angry her feeling
obviously overwhelmed and helpless and
I'm gonna presume to make any judgments
or assumptions that her about her at all
based on that so um and so I had to stop
myself there and yeah I just feel like
we we can choose to cut people slack or
not we can choose to see the worst in
them or not we could choose to give them
the benefit of the doubt or not and
that's a choice that we make
and especially when it comes to parents
I just think that sometimes we should
stop and say look this is not excusing
everything but sometimes we stop and say
listen maybe this is just a rough time a
is just a rough day and this could be a
great parent 99.9% I thought maybe you
caught the point 1% where they don't
really have it together
and I say all of this maybe somewhat
selfishly because as a parent myself I I
do I would want people to extend that
grace to me if they ever caught me in
public in the moment you know not
reacting exactly how I'm supposed to
react which I have been guilty of in the
past I admit all right um so we will we
leave I'll leave it there with that
sappy note for the for the holidays that
was my one that was my little one it was
a glimpse of humanity and generosity
from me so that's it's a holiday miracle
already it is possible folks and thanks
everyone for watching listening have a
happy Thanksgiving
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
it's Thanksgiving and you know what that
means
pumpkin pie and mashed potatoes and a
bunch of insufferable leftist think
pieces
preparing liberals to suffer the torture
of speaking to a single conservative
even once even when they're related to
even for just a couple of hours we will
examine how liberals talk about talking
to us that and the history of
Thanksgiving check it out on the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]